I want to mention something that's
really cool
before the pandemic and I want to stress
this before the pandemic you did a photo
shoot for People magazine in honor of
Earth Day yes now it's come out and
you're on the cover congratulations
thank you very much thank you very much
yeah it's for a really good cause it's
for NRDC is that right yes the Natural
Resources Defense Council I'm on the
board of that organization and its
really really about we're talking about
the climate crisis and how it affects
everyone and how it's a non partisan
issue and that's very much a part of
this article and and frankly you know
there's an there's an aspect of this
pandemic right now that really there's
an overlap here and the overlap is that
science should be determining
determining policy and and and that's
true of the pandemic and that's true of
the climate crisis that we're we're
feeling right now so it's just a
heightened awareness about that and keep
that conversation going and because I'm
a I'm an environmentalist and I think
really probably most people are if they
gave it some thought
yeah I think it's fair to say that if
there's I'd like to try and look for the
silver lining and if there's a silver
lining in this crisis maybe it's that
people will start to accept that science
is extremely useful and yeah science
saves lives and maybe investing more in
science listening to what it's telling
us probably not a bad idea and you need
out of this yes